ah look who hasn't had Gay Thoughts who
well but Chris said that you just had to
you know Tinker with things yeah he said
that because that sounds a lot better
than we're going to gut it with a
machete
okay you're a jerk I'm sorry I'm sorry
these are real people in a real town
working in a real building with real
feelings this building has feelings
maybe there's a lot of history in this
one maybe it's does how can you be so
blaso because I didn't cause these
problems Miss nope your government did
I'll get what I need from the
spreadsheets
thanks what's a not gay way to ask him
to go camping with
me H um uh this is something Justin
Derek and B are gay but often on
occasion April will have relations with
Derek right crazy stuff discuss that
there's not much more to discuss you
kind of explained it
all who else is gay soft opening
tomorrow from now on everyone call me
Kristen because I am wigging out right
now yeah we're not even close to being
ready they're not even done painting
that sign it says Tom's by actually no
that's good we're ready I just want to
thank my family my friends most
importantly my best best man Mr Tom
haford oh oh coolest guy I know and
ladies he's single I think you're not
still married are you no but you you're
straight yes John ralphi is just a
friend yeah
yeah what could you possibly need at
6:00 in the morning we couldn't read
your writing and we need to know the sex
of our baby I'm watching cartoons with
my son Daddy and El one is on stop it
hey what's up beautiful John ralphio
live in the guest house what do you say
you you and I get together in a special
way I I'm pregnant the more than marrier
with my baby well you can come too
beautiful look at that I guess sometimes
I call men beautiful too I guess I'm
openminded as hell I think you're pretty
good luing thank you tux do you take
flipper to be your lawfully wedded
wife I Do I Do by the power vested in me
from the Department of Parks and
Recreation I Now Pronounce You
husband and
[Applause]
wife
oh okay well at least they're married I
say making babies um not those two those
are both boy
Penguins I'm sorry tux and flipper are
both boys so you should have pronounced
them husband husband technically that's
awesome
still you couldn't have asked for better
weather this place is
outstanding great call Lesly no look
even Ben dancing hey Leslie some guy who
owns a gay bar sent you a cake Pon has a
gay bar yeah the
Bulge it's behind my house the Bulge is
a gay bar ah the nights I wasted there
Donna this is crazy typhoon is an artist
and the human head is his canvas just
listen he going to cut the man's hair
you're going to charge him $8 it'll take
you 4 minutes so just shut up and make
the man look like this
fine so
typhoon what do you like to do for fun
I'm writing an electronic Opera about
Britney Murphy and I do the chandelier
design for my friend's drag puppet show
no further questions all I really want
to do is dance except lately all the
good Warehouse Raves are filled with
Euro
trash Euro trash I like that it is
indeed a garbage continent yes oh my God
I had the worst time in Berlin last May
everyone was on their stupid bikes I was
like
ew please talk more about how you hate
Europe and
bicycles on the house Leslie oh thank
you I'm sort of a gay hero you know why
tonight's fun cuz everyone's so gay and
they know how to have fun and the
dancing just it's everyone is just who
they are and who they are is just Stone
Cold gay it's Leslie NOP Leslie NOP
you're my hero Leslie you are looking
hot oh thank you Ben I'm really enjoying
this hug so nice but I need to tell you
something this one is on us well if it's
free Leslie
no she she's lovely no she wants to
recruit
you no no no no oh my okay please please
please
please gentlemen first of all I would
just like to say thank you so much for
throwing me this party especially on a
night when the CTS are
playing we love
you
okay on this is
[Applause]
green okay well I wanted to tell you
that I wasn't really trying to take a
stand when I married those
[Applause]
penguin my
name I just have one thing to say
together we can change Pony forever
[Applause]
[Music]
let's hey there how's it going great
thanks can I buy you a drink oh I'm very
flattered but this is my stunningly
gorgeous date in perets oh hi hi sorry
oh no problem in fact let me buy all of
you a drink for being so welcoming today
Leslie hey hey this is my boyfriend
Derek this is Derrick's boyfriend Ben he
hey oh wait sorry what's the situation
what do you mean how does this work
Derek is gay but he's straight for me
but he's gay for Ben and Ben's really
gay for Derek and I hate Ben it's not
that
complicated I'm having such a nice time
tonight I've met many interesting people
and there's two bisexual guys here and I
got both of their phone
numbers Hey
guys hey remember my boyfriend Derek and
his boyfriend Ben yeah hi it's totally
okay that you didn't wear a costume I
did I'm a straight
person hey sorry I'm late
see nice creu in buddy the gentleman
over by the bar there sent you over this
glass of wine and here a business
card okay
fine we are gathered here today to join
Craig Middlebrooks and typhoon Montalban
in holy matrimony I don't know about
this I'm very scared oh just relax you
nervous Nelly you're right we love each
other and the tax break is substantial
will the best man please present the
Rings good luck you
two typhoon my love happy
anniversary do you have any regrets not
one not a single one do you have any
regrets are you kidding thousands most
recently this trout sorry it's a little
bit lame right now but we'll get it
going I passed a gay Halloween party to
be here do you know how much fun gay
Halloween parties are last year I saw
three Jonas Brothers make out with three
Robert Patterson's was
amazing can't believe this is a gay bar
yeah especially with that heterosexual
Cowboy greeting us on the way in have
fun last night I had three drinks named
after me so that's pretty fun plus Ben
and Derrick are taking me shopping on
Saturday and we are going to find out my
actual bra
size I guess I'm kind of like Queen of
The Gaze fully for
you